[Musique]
territoire d'infos public sénat sud
radio
notre invité politique de 8 heures c'est
gilbert collard bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes vous dit la
secrétaire nationale du rassemblement
bleu marine et pour vous interroger à
mes côtés ce matin c'est christophe
bordée de sud radio bouge au christ un
jour michaël szames s de public sénat
bonjour michael merci d'être avec
bonjour
gilbert collard des fêtes de l'extrême
aux législatives en hollande au profit
de la droite libérale
hier est ce que cela laisse présager une
défaite du front national pour la
présidentielle est ce que c'est un
mauvais signe venu des pays-bas pour
vous alors je peux vous dire que s'il
pleut aux pays bas il fait beau ici au
cas où vous n'auriez pas vu la météo n'a
pas de cause on vient à passer parfois
et parfois il y a du soleil sur les pays
bas et il pleut ici non or à bord de
relation de cause à effet savoir vous
dire il ya une progression du parti de
la liberté qui est qui et qui est très
net dans un contexte de construction
électorale qui pas du tout la même que
que la nôtre puisque à la
proportionnelle et c'est bon et il y a
quand même le fait que le premier
ministre ça ne peut pas vous échapper à
vous qui est des observateurs attentifs
intelligent perspicace de la vie
politique
le premier ministre a quand même viré le
ministre turc allons bien évidemment sur
les terres du leader du parti de la
liberté pour vous ça a joué donc
quelque part il ya des empreintes de
comportements et des emprunts d'idées
qui sont très significatifs
maintenant comme je vous le disais tout
à l'heure la météorologie politique elle
n'est pas la même partout est fort
heureusement quand il fait beau ici plus
là bas quand il pleut là-bas il fait
beau ici
alors ce qui se passe en france selon le
ministre de la justice
les conditions aujourd'hui sont réunis
pour une sortie de l'état d'urgence est
ce que vous soutenez jean jacques urvoas
j'ai toujours considéré que l'état
d'urgence ne servait pas à grand chose
compte tenu des lois que nous avons à
condition qu'on les applique à mais
malheureusement comme on ne les
appliquent pas on se sert de l'effet
placebo de l'état d'urgence le principe
de précaution dont je suis pas un adepte
exige qu'on maintienne l'état d'urgence
la dernière fois que françois hollande
avait dit qu'on allait suspendre l'état
d'urgence on a eu à l'attentât mais
d'ailleurs les zones à bhl de dire ça
maintenant
alors qu'on est en pleine norman
électorale et de tout de toute manière
il se passe quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre de 2,2 de l'entonnoir il
faudrait vraiment qu'à la finde c'est à
dire la fin de ce quinquennat on décore
plusieurs ministres de l'ordre de
l'entonnoir parce que en pleine période
électorale
en pleine campagne présidentielle alors
que la violence est quand même partout
oser dire que la période de l'état
d'urgence ne semblent plus nécessaire me
paraît une folie psychologique une faute
politique une faute politique une une
erreur tactique même c'est c'est un peu
comme s'ils ont provoqué les les les
terroristes c'est un peu comme si on les
bat comme si on leur disait les feux
passent au vert on peut y aller starwood
oui oui en même temps ça veut dire aussi
aller c'est terminé c'est terminé le
terrorisme ne nous inquiète plus on a
plus de raison de prendre les mesures de
protection
ce qui est vrai c'est que cet état
d'urgence n'a pas empêché les nuits de
boue n'a pas empêché qu'on incendies des
fonctionnaires de police qu'on agresse
ddd
une policière de la bac au point de la
défigurer que que des tirs de mortier et
prestations en faveur de françois fillon
l'autre joueur manifestations mais n'a
pas été violente se lâchèrent normes
c'était une manifestation quand même nom
et on est bien entre la manifestation en
faveur de françois fillon et la
manifestation des nuits de boue d'aider
à 10 t on à bien quand la compagnie
c'est quand même pas la même chose sont
pas les mêmes confettis que les
policiers reçoivent un élan française
selon vous est ce qu'ils sont pour cette
levée ou pas c'est un sondage ifop
fiducial 61% des français sont contre
cette levée de l'état d'urgence aux gens
qu'ils ont raison parce que c'est la
question du principe de précaution et
puis pourquoi donner même si quelque
part il peut être dans la réalité
inopérant pourquoi donner un signal de
désengagement
quel intérêt on a à donner un signal de
désengagement quels intérêts ça on parle
de l'état d'urgence on parle du
terrorisme et puis il ya la sécurité au
quotidien la sécurité des français dans
ce même sondage dont parlait michael 91%
des français souhaitent le retour de la
police de proximité c'est un des thèmes
de cette campagne présidentielle est ce
que vous êtes favorable au retour de la
police de proximité dans les quartiers
dans l'éclairage et c'était vraiment si
vous pouvez retrouver des documents
me concernant je prends pas d avis de
recherche je parle de documents
techniques vous verrez que j'ai été un
des premiers à mettre en cause la
suppression par gaston defferre
on l'a oublié cela des commissariats de
quartier
ça remonte à l'époque de gars sont de
fait on vous dit il faut un renoir de la
police de proximité mais aussi marine le
pen est élue présidente par exemple moi
je vais beaucoup plus loin je suis pour
le rétablissement des cartes des
commissariats de quartier à l'époque
vous aviez un juge de paix d'un quartier
vous aviez le commissaire qu'on pouvait
aller voir auquel on peut éventuellement
fournir des renseignements un gaston
defferre dans une espèce de deux
d'erreurs monumentales
j'en avais discuté avec lui à l'époque
du reste avait décidé de refermer les
commissariats de proximité armée ou pas
paul bulcke police de proximité armé
d'un pistolet d'un sifflet et d'une
matraque
gilbert collard un ex-dirigeant
identitaire suspendu du front national
en vue de son exclusion suite à des
propos négationnistes tenus dans un
documentaire télé vous le savez est ce
que c'est la preuve qu'il ya toujours
des brebis galeuses au front national
que le ménage n'a pas été fait ni
terminée écoutez nous avons des mehdi
meklat nous avons des mecques la voilà
vous les avez chez vous puisque mekla à
public sénat non bravo c'est bien
c'était bien de le dire parce que on l'a
vu avec insistance d'autres confirmés
par ailleurs ailleurs bon bon ailleurs
qui s'est alors qu'ici bref plein de
chaînes de télé hbo nous avons
quelquefois hélas un ou deux mekla c'est
vrai et il faut les virer tout de suite
ce que marine a décidé de faire mais ce
que je trouve extraordinaire si on peut
se parler librement dans un pays libre
avec une information libre
puisqu'on n'est pas efficient ici chez
monsieur draghi un bon c'est un thème
récurrent un parc drive au front
national
l'espace parce que c'est une réalité
voilà donc la réalité est récurrente
bien évidemment la manière dont ces huit
se comporte la manière dont ce reportage
est fait est absolument scandaleuse
c'est des comportements de deux flics
d'ancien régime quoi on vient sans dire
on est journaliste
en prêtant qu'on fait de l'immersion
c'est ça comme si on était des sous
marins c'est à dire que ces 8 à plus à
la faute
la provocation ça existe vous savez ça
ça peut exister je vous garantis moi je
parie que si on immerge une équipe de
télé mal intentionnés dans votre
rédaction
on va en sortir avec des éléments très
intéressants et partout on rappelle que
ça peut être au monde ça peut être par
courriel que c'est vite n'est pas la
propriété de patrick drahi bien entendu
mais de vivendi avant ça devrait bien de
le dire ça oui oui non message de jeu
jugée pour les téléspectateurs mais là
qu'est patrick drahi là il s'agit pas de
la chaîne de fatigue non mais attendez
il n'y a pas que chez drahi cas des
et kenza mais c'est autant dire
que toutes les télévisions sont en train
de faire une campagne contre le front
national c'est ce que voulait dire
il faut être faut être aveugle pour ne
pas s'en rendre quand je pose la
question mais moi je dirais tant mieux
j'ai fait une confidence rien s'il
n'était pas au front national
la campagne qui est menée contre le
front contre marine
ces complicités de journalistes qui se
réunissent pour dire du mal du franc ici
ferait que j'irai au front tellement ça
ça m'insupporte
cette coalition d'aidé des prétendus
bonne conscience du monde de france info
de france inter de libération système
qui ne vivent que de ses inventions en
plus tous tout ce système me dégoûte
ils sont interdépendants les uns des
autres ils s'auto décor qu'il sera au
pouvoir
il y aura plus tout ça il y aura plus ce
média là faudra faire table rase mais
une fois que marine le pen sera au
pouvoir nous envahir à ce qui est une
égalité de traitement à l'égard de tout
le monde quand même marine elle a donné
son parrainage à gué nous c'est pas rien
on peut en parler ça montre quand même
que ça monte mais ils se présentent tous
comme des démocrates mais en réalité
leur seul souci c'est de garder la
gamelle
regardez regardez les sauvegardes
estrosi qui sait dire avec les bois
socialiste bertrand qui ces l'irec les
bois sociale interdit avait quand on est
quand on est de droite je trouve qu'on
n'a pas trop honneur à aller se faire
élire par des gens de gauche que vous
combattez et qui vous combattent et
lleno qui se fait parrainer par marine
le pen
mais keynote le petit guaino à touches
de droite mais guaino a toujours dit sa
sympathie pour marion maréchal-le pen
par exemple et est ce que les digues
sont en train de sauter là entre la loi
bill front national sont à l'heure
actuelle que personne ne veut voir parce
que tout le monde tremblote dans sa
tisane le front national va prendre le
pouvoir c'est que ce sont les ce sont
les digues souterraine qui craque
il ya plein de gens qui ne viendront pas
dire ici qu'ils vont voter pour nous
mais qui voteront pour nous parce que
ils en ont marre le maire ait l'air le
maire et leurs cris qui vous a rejoint
c'est quoi c'est une preuve de courage
c'est une preuve de conviction aussi je
veux dire voilà bon mais pourquoi si je
peux me permettre
pourquoi quand quelqu'un nous rejoint il
faut immédiatement qui est un
commentaire du
style et ce n'est pas un reproche que je
vous fais un il est courageux il à
vapeur c'est un modèle non mais ça
montre bien à contrario que il y as
contre nous vraiment toute une
propagande il faut bien dire les choses
comme gisement gmr collard avait vu la
situation de françois fillon
aujourd'hui est ce que finalement vous
êtes en train de faire vous vous
souhaitez faire une opa sur les
républicains
car non non je crois pas je crois que je
crois que on est on est dans la
situation du glissement de terrain
politique les cet électorat vient vers
nous parce qu'il se rend compte que que
nous on pactise pas avec ceux là même
qui les assassine
quand on voit monsieur estrosi par
exemple bon qui mène campagne contre le
front national qui se fait élire par la
gauche mais c'est un traître
enfin il est entre heroes est un traître
mais moi je le dis très clairement je
pourrais lui dire s'il était enfin tout
ça veut dire que demain tous ceux qui
vont se réunir contre marine le pen si
jamais elle était au second tour de la
présidentielle seront des traîtres
pourquoi vous vous je vous pose la
question et ne reposait pas l'avoir car
si vous posez la question était un point
d'interrogation pour un point
d'exclamation grande et très pur voilà
bon ce que ce que je veux dire c'est que
quand on a affaire à un homme comme
monsieur estrosi par exemple quelqu'un
qui a eu le comique de se prendre pour
papy fait de la résistance en puissance
un plan le résistant ou danse on est bon
bon qui a été proche du front national à
une époque en plus bon qui se fait élire
avec les voix socialistes lesquels
socialiste il combat il combat et qui
aujourd'hui se prétend indépendant des
socialistes alors qu'il a été élu grâce
à eux qui sont en train de poignarder
fillon mais c'est pas un traître c'est
quoi c'est quoi j'avais une question un
peu annexe les comptes officiels de
bercy d'autres comptes de twitter
notamment été piratés depuis qu'ils vont
s'amener de la turquie hier ça venait de
la russie est ce que vous estimez que la
campagne présidentielle est prise en
otage parce que je peux vous dire c'est
par erreur j'ai diffusé tous mes comptes
tous mes numéros de comptes twitter y
compris en avait ça je n'ai pas été
piratés parce que j'ai un très bon
système de protection avoir eu vent des
comptes bon l'erreur je la cimade a pas
été faite par mois mais je la sim
mais je n'ai pas je pense que messi
celle de protection sont très efficaces
alors j'ai du mal à croire que l'état ne
soit pas en mesure de ce pot de ce
bronze de se protéger
s'il n'est pas en mesure de se protéger
c'est comme un état qui j'ai eu mon club
[Musique]